zwei millionen euro meine laut sprechen
ich hab gar keine lautsprecher an meinem
pc die teuersten dinge der welt
das cool dass ich den titel vorlesen
kann nur und herzlich willkommen hier
heute zum heutigen video ich stelle euch
heute 17 teuerste die tollsten 17 die
die sachen vor die teuer sind ob acer
jetzt kommen jetzt locker leute in den
kommentaren von wegen ein bisschen wenn
ihren hater seit ich werde euch nicht
die 17 teuersten sachen vorstellen die
wirklich chronologisch in der
reihenfolge die teuersten gegenstelle
der welt sind die welt ist das teuerste
ist ja alles okay aber ich werde euch
beispielsweise so etwas vorstellen die
einen hamburger der aber der teuerste
hamburger ist den ich je gesehen habe
oder eine hose die nicht normal
irgendwie 50 euro kostet wie eine hose
sondern halt voll viel geld oder so
ballett beginnen das erste was ich euch
heute zeigen möchte ist diese hose die
sie hat scheiße aus es ist irgendwie so
eine typische pose die damals in den
80ern hatten dann oder verbünde mit
ihrer gitarre herum gezogen
diese jeans kostet 25.000 euro 25.000
euro meine komplette kleidung zusammen
kostet nicht mal 10.000 euro also hey es
ist schon teuer ich mein okay von der
hose gibt insgesamt acht exemplare auf
der welt und sieht von levels und hier
ist also das kann man irgendwo noch ein
bisschen verschiedenen 25.000 euro das
ist ein auto das hier ist das iphone 3gs
supreme heroes heißt das und ja das ist
jetzt kein iphone 6 oder kein iphone
diesen sondern wirklich in rheinhessen
von der technik her ist sonnig trasse
als jetzige handys allerdings liegt der
unterschied zwischen diesem handy und
den heutigen iphone 7 beispielsweise
darin dass dieses handy drei millionen
euro kostet die enbw wer sich das kauft
fick dich gib mir geld wenn man sich
diese website anschaut denkt man erst
mal so ok ist irgendeine versicherung
website
und wenn man sich dann irgendwie als
unternehmer denkt vielleicht diese
domain ist cool muss man nämlich ganze
16 millionen euro auf den tisch blättern
um die domain zu bekommen die domain
heißt in sure dot com und steht auch im
guinness world record buch als teuerste
domain der welt das hier ist das gemälde
la folie
man merkt dass sich franzose bin
definitiv nein es ist von picasso
gemalte also es ist klar dass es jetzt
kein billiges bild oder gemälde ist oder
so aber ich hätte nie gedacht dass es
180 millionen euro kostet irgendwie
besteht das video nur daraus dass ich
irgendwas sage und dann den preis sage
oder nur noch schweigen
das ist doch viel zu krank kennt ihr das
wenn ihr in der großstadt fahrt und die
suche die ganze zeit ein paar platz und
ich denke so wackelig vereinfacht ins
parkhaus und dann kommt er nach zehn
minuten wieder unter 20 euro bezahlen
es gibt ein paar kingsport in manhattan
das ist dieser hier also in new york und
der kostet einfach mal wenn man sein
auto abstellen will und sich den tatort
quasi kaufen will eine million euro
dafür kriegst du sechs einzel
familienhäuser das hier ist der rein und
dann würde jetzt vielleicht denken das
hat irgendjemand mit seinem handy
aufgenommen und ist ein stinknormales
foto vom rhein nähe
das kostet vier millionen euro und das
bild heißt rein zwei das heißt einer ist
wahrscheinlich einfach dahin gegangen
hat ein foto davon noch ein foto davon
gemacht und dann hat er halt das zweite
bild genommen und es kostet vier
millionen euro hessischen ring der
die frau und ihr mann und 16 millionen
euro für diese jagd gehört angeblich im
asiatischen business menschen und die in
der nacht sind über 100.000 kilogramm
gold verarbeitet dies dekorierten
knochen von einem tier ex und sie heißt
ist ihre erste hieß es
rust hustensaft history supreme 5
milliarden euro ich sage dazu nichts
mehr das hier ist ein fucking vogelfeder
und sie kostet 8000 euro wo leben wir
man es ist eine feder von julia vogel
und er ist vom aussterben bedroht also
deswegen sind die federn da sehr selten
sehr wertvoll aber acom 8000 euro für
eine vogelfeder was will man damit
machen gleich gehen einige von euch
öfter sind clubs feiern und gucken sich
dann dort vielleicht auch mal die
getränke liste an und da sieht man ja
immer okay man bezahlt er jetzt irgendwo
eine wodka die vielleicht im supermarkt
in euro kosten würde kosten bezahlt man
im profi ca 180 euro das teuerste was
ich jähnigen dem club gesehen habe war
glaube ich irgend eine flasche für 4000
euro das war so eine riesige flasche und
das hier ist irgendein jump anja den ich
nicht mal wirklich kannte heisig monopol
1907 heißt dieser und da kostet eine
flasche 25.000 euro ist wieder so teuer
wie ein auto wie ich lese gerade das
früher mal ein schiff mit 2000 dieser
flaschen an bord untergegangen
es sind einfach 50 millionen euro ich
muss das meer absuchen
diese lautsprecher wiegen insgesamt über
fünf tonnen werden hergestellt aus
erkrath aluminium und kosten zwei
millionen euro zwei millionen euro meine
laut sprechen ich habe gar keine
lautsprecher meinem pc dieses haus heißt
antalya mumbai das ist ein haus in
downtown indien und über 600 leute
arbeiten dort dauerhaft
sind dort fest angestellt 2 milliarden
euro das hier ist die royal penthouse
suite im hotel wilson genever und dort
kostet eine nacht 65.000 euro eher gut
also das hotelzimmer hat insgesamt zehn
zimmer und dazu noch sieben bäder also
irgendwas ist verständlich aber 65.000
euro pro nach dieses klavier ist nicht
anders als alle anderen klaviere also
man kann dort genauso gut drauf spielen
es ist in waging hergestellt und es
kostet aber drei millionen euro
verteidiger dass dort tomahawk v10
superbike ist von null auf hundert in
2,5 sekunden und hat einen topspeed von
über 480 km h s kostet halt auf 700.000
euro
das stattliche summe wieser burger
heissenberger extra papa und ich hab ich
hab jetzt hungert ich habe mega hunger
gerade alter der wird verkauft in dem
restaurant in new york und den
zusammengehalten von essbarem gold und
das kostet ein burger 300 euro dafür
kriegst du circa 300 cheeseburger beim
mac ist und jetzt habe ich noch viel
mehr hunger der letzte gegen den ich
euch heute zeigen wollte ist dieser
ferrari hier das ist nämlich ein 1962
der ferrari 250 gto und er kostet 35
millionen euro
irgendso ein britischer sammler hat sich
den dann gegönnt und ich hoffe er hat
damit keinen unfall gebaut
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe nicht gefallen wenn es
getan hat lasst mal bitten fed lag da
und bei 35 millionen likes tausche ich
jeden like in euro um und kaufte mit den
1962 er ferrari übrigens leute erster
zwölfter dick im kalender eintragen dort
kommen nämlich sechs neue produkte in
den lukas shop und ich wird krass also
erste 12 den kalender eintragen kauft
alle menschen als von luca luka minister
von de